welcome to our webinar everyone this is
when good PPC campaigns go bad a deep
look into your related data AdWords
campaigns that used to do pretty well
and then suddenly are falling flat so
today Google Ads expert Bret get is's
with us and he's going to show us how to
autopsy any of your perished
pay-per-click ads and bring them back to
life we'll also look beyond Google ads
reporting and you know how to get better
insights using Google Data studio I just
want to introduce to you brad geddes
is the author of advanced google adwords
and he's the co-founder of the
award-winning company analysis an
automatic platform for ad testing and
PPC recommendation
Brad frequently writes columns for
search engine land and eco moderates the
AdWords forum on a webmaster world
he's also key noted in spoken in more
than 125 conferences and has led more
than 100 AdWords seminars plus he's the
course advisor for the digital marking
curriculum here at Sibley learn so
welcome Brad and thank you for your
patience and especially thank you for
joining us with all this amazing
information
ah thanks stamping stand good to be here
as always and to everyone you know on
the on the webinar today what we're
gonna go through right is looking at how
metrics are interrelated so when
something suddenly goes bad or it goes
good very it you have to figure out
right what the root causes if it's good
you want more of it if it's bad of
course you want to go fix it and the
issue here rate is it's usually often
not found by the analysts you've got a
client or your boss calls you up and
says hey are conversions are up 19% and
sometimes that's not a good thing or hey
we we are spends up 72% why and hey if
your conversions up a hundred percent it
will spend the sudden who's actually
pretty good and so what we're going to
do is sort of dig through this chart and
look at how data flows so at the top
level right we have before the click
items all right this is your search
volume how many impressions you
and why you lose them and then once our
ad can be displayed right our impression
then we can get clicks from that right
so our data falls down direct clicks
which is functions of CTR is none of
course accumulates or cost data someone
goes to our website now they can convert
or and that kids through our conversion
data and so you know we always want to
start right by saying well what's our
volume were working with right did our
volume go up or down and if it went up
or down
why so what we're usually looking at
right is a time frame compared to
another time frame right so it could be
one month compared to that the previous
month it could be compared to you over a
year and we'll look at which one to use
in a minute for both of those now you
lose impressions for certain reason or
there's this huge search time out there
now you may capture a specific part of
those impressions and so we lose
impressions right usually based upon our
impression shared budget right or a loss
impression share rank and and those are
influenced by our budgets or quality
scores our bids so forth and so we're
using looking for is where did something
go down right was it in our search
impression share was it in our lost
budgets right where do we lose it and
then once we find that we can start to
drill down into more root causes so for
instance right if volume and impression
share change right things we want to
start looking at initially well do we
change our targeting do we get a bunch
of negative keywords or new keywords
right did we change some match types did
the PPC engine change their targeting
rules right this happens every so often
match type definitions are changed or
audience definitions are changed so if
it's not a targeting change right next
we want to look at seasonality right so
this is where you get into two
comparisons we're going to look at in a
second year over year versus month over
month and then lastly budgets so when
you think about trending right to say
hey all right what do we want to compare
against is that the last month is it the
is it the same time period
last year this often gets into your
seasonality effects so for instance
right here we have the purple charts to
2016 the green charts 2017 now if we
were to compare March to February of any
year doesn't matter what your we pick we
look like it looks like March is a
really bad year because we're getting
into the low of our seasonality so just
doing that March versus February
comparisons are not a very good
comparison in a seasonal business
raising like that we want to do
year-over-year right where if right we
don't have that huge right u-shaped sort
of trend we're much more linear they
want to do more month-over-month
comparisons or week over week
comparisons so that goes for all the
comparisons you're doing whether it's
clicks impressions conversions etc so
then if we're losing impressions shared
due to budget alright well the questions
really are did the budgets change do
they go up or do they go down and this
all and don't forget the shared budgets
if you lose more impressions due to
budget and budgets did not change then
it's pretty much always your cost per
click went up a lot which meant now you
could afford less total clicks which
means your budget run runs out earlier
therefore right you have a larger and
precious your lawsuit of budget changes
and so we think about why do we lose and
pressures right those are the main
things now it is useful to trend budgets
all right because lost impression share
budget is very good for looking at hey
if we changed our budget how would this
affect our data right so this is really
good information right you can get to
your boss your client saying hey if we
change our budget from 120 dollars a day
to 200 dollars a day we're going to see
a you know 20 percent increase in
conversions right and we'll see our CPA
increase of X right that's that's
important stuff it's also useful to look
at impression share budget trends to see
if you're gaining a lot
of impressions right will you eventually
hit your cap so for instance in this
account right the blue lines is the kyun
of daily budget available to be spent
but the red line is what we actually
spent so in November we spent below our
budget so we would have no impression
share loss due to budget in January
right we almost got for a budget not
quite so I'm going to have a little
impression she lost but it is pretty low
by February our budget was totally
capped right so we actually hit them and
we probably lose more impression share
budget now this is what happens when
this is a seasonal business where there
are actually high season it is February
and March and they're building up to it
so you have your targeting with a good
budget in November and by the time it
gets to February you actually can't
reach all the available impressions and
so that's another reason that your
impressions your budget loss can be
effective is this due to the volume now
if you're losing a precious share due to
rank right one of the things we want to
look at is average position and we're
going to talk about the new metrics in
in a moment and so if we're losing it
did a rank one of the big things is did
our quality scores change if our quality
scores dropped right that means our
a-drinkin is going to go down which
means we can show in less options so
then our our lost impression share rank
is going to increase did your impression
top percentage has changed so that's
where the new metrics will get a second
that Google introduced last year and
will be the metric going forward
September of this year is as good a
verage position is going to be sunsetted
and lastly did [ __ ] change
significantly if you increase your bid
or decrease your bid a lot it's going to
have a major effect on your ad rank
which then can either right see you lose
more impressions due to a drink loss or
less impressions so if you see in your
impression volume one of those changes
whether it's impression share loss
budget impression shell loss ranking
better a change this is where you want
to start digging into why that change
happens we also like to graph a quality
score over time this lets us see how
things are changing right so we can
anticipate hey our quality score and
this is where the quality score for an
account our quality score at the end of
January for our expected CTR went from
below average to average which means
we're going to see a large increase in
in a drinks across the board which also
means then we may spend more budget
because we're going to be in higher
positions and therefore we can get more
clicks now if you see that your
impression volume hasn't changed that
much right and you've got differences in
metrics then we move right from
impression - when click parts happen so
you get an impression if someone clicks
on it you obviously get a click and
those two metrics determine our
click-through rates right in every time
you get a click then you pay a CPC right
your clicks in your CPC determine what
your cost is so CTR has a huge amount of
influential factors in your account so
if you see there's a major CTR change in
your account right then we have to think
about okay did we do some reorganization
right because that relationship of add
of keywords to add in an ad group right
really affects CTR did we change your ad
rotation settings right did we add a
bunch of new ads and Google messed up
our ads or with your ad rotation did we
change some ad tests do we introduce new
ones or pause like old losers if you
pause a bunch of low CTR ads of course
you're going to have a higher
click-through rate again more clicks
more cost did you change your ad types
right responsive search ads are much
more volatile in terms of CTR jumping up
and down then etas are a lot more static
did your impressions change that you're
actually getting clicks for so if your
top impressions share rate goes up a lot
your eyes are sewn on top position
more often well that's going to be a
higher click-through rate than low
impression shares and when you're add to
the bottom of the page so that makes a
big difference if you add changed
keywords change any targeting that
affects CTR and so CTR if you see a
change is one of the most the most
influential factors across the account
for a click volume it also has some of
the most factors that affect that single
metric because every change can affect
CTR now
doulas can get rid of average position
in September this year it'll go away and
it's being replaced by two new metrics
we have impression top and impression
absolute top so what impression top is
the percentage of times that your ad was
displayed on the top part of the page
right we're impressions absolute top is
the percentage of times your average two
in a position number one so these are
are a little bit harder to deal with
because there's a sort of percentages
right than average position and a nice
easy number but average position is
highly misleading if you see your
average position is three we don't know
is hey that's always the top of the page
or for that search query Google only
shows two on the top and that's always
bottom of page right three doesn't tell
you that it just says here's a number
and but it's an easy number to work with
and understand so the newer numbers
really show you your visibility right
top versus bottom much clearer but it's
a few numbers in statistics you're
working out to see it so it takes a
little more mental processing to work
with it now when you're using broad
match your quality score and budget can
affect your CTR which is sort of an odd
statement so two as an example here
let's say we have the broad match
keyword laptop in our account and let's
say our quota score is a three and we're
little budget cat so Google is not going
to take much Liberty in how they match
that word because we have a low-quality
score
we'll probably show for laptop and maybe
some of the they use laptop and the
plurals and stuff but we're definitely
not going to show for four brand names
and for say at our computer now our
Qualis will goes up or we have more
budget available right either one else
happens then Google start showing right
your broad match keyword for even more
queries now these queries are not quite
as related right to your initial keyword
so your CTR goes down claws roll goes up
more budget goes up more you may have
the keyword laptop and you're being
shown for the keyword towers or power
computers right different keyword
different ad than what the user searched
for really low CTR so sometimes CTR is
just affected by your match types as
broad match gets a better quality score
usually what you see is that broad match
key we get to lower CTR now as always
always if you're doing at testing pause
you're losing ads we've been through
this in previous webinars before but
when you're when you get above 3 ads in
an ad group Google's ad serving gets
really wonky at times and so usually
when you're testing you're testing just
two or three ads at once and then you
find those losers pause them so you push
more impressions to you're better at
converting ads which again because those
ads often have higher CTR s and losers
is going to get you more clicks and
spend more budget now cost per click is
one of the most straightforward of all
the metrics you set a bid competitor set
bids based upon your quality score in a
drink right you pay a penny more than to
beat the a drink of the person below you
so if you see large changes to cpc's
it's generally competitors really change
their bids a lot you change your bids a
lot or your Quality Score went really up
a lot or down a lot
I'm usually CPC by itself is very
stagnant unless someone else is making
major changes to either bids or quality
scores
but so we want to look at though it is
auction insights because while we don't
see competitor bids what we can see is
how the competitors changed right their
average position their position above us
rates so if we look at here's our data
and here's some analysis and suddenly
they're there top of page rate
skyrockets and their position above us
goes up quite a bit well then either
they just raise their bids a lot or they
just raise their quality score lot
assuming you haven't made changes so
that can tell you or if we want to
maintain this we need to either also
change our bids or write work on our
Quality Score and add extensions so
forth so cost has by far the least
influential factors of every metric near
account cost is the number of clicks you
got and your average CPC that's it so
number of clicks you get has a lot of
factors because I could send a CTR in
impressions right how much your CPC is
have a lot of factors from competitor
bids in your bid standpoint but cost has
very few factors and usually when
there's big cost differences it's
because you got a lot more or a lot less
clicks so then we get our impression so
now we got our clicks we try to qualify
the user so we get the right clicks they
get sent off to our website right and
then from there we try to make them you
know converting users and so we think
about our a conversion standpoint right
we've got our conversions which is a
factor of the number of clicks who
received in our conversion rate and then
of course we have our cost data or CPC
data combined with our conversions tells
us how much we pay for a conversion then
we may be tracking for e-commerce
we're probably tracking revenue amount
as well and can't render revenue numbers
right so we think about did any of these
metrics have large changes right that
our conversions change in this case 55%
big change the cost per conversion
twelve conversion rate minus 20 and
minus 20 is a pretty big number right
cost per conversion twelve
percent higher not not huge compared to
our conversion change rights we're
looking for where the big numbers so if
our conversions change well number one
did our clicks go up or down because if
our conversion rate is static our clicks
go up a lot but our conversions go up a
lot did our conversion rate change that
that's the number to obsess over right
if you your your conversion rate
suddenly goes down a lot that's going to
affect a lot of things you're doing and
so conversion rates usually go down if
you're targeting changes right something
on the website could obviously get
broken or some Tracking's out working
correctly so if you see major changes in
conversions
especially when it's conversion rates
that's when you want to drill down into
what campaign and potentially what ad
groups do this happen in so we can
really really examine that data to to
fix it right to put things back how they
should be
now if your cost per conversion changes
that your big questions did your CPC go
up or down right and then did your
conversion rate change it's real simple
right because if you spent more but your
conversion rate didn't change your cost
per conversion is the same you just have
more conversions so if your CPC went up
or down a lot that could definitely have
effect and cost per conversion and as
your conversion rate goes down of course
cost per conversion goes up it's an
inverse relationship now it's useful to
look at each of these metrics
individually a lot of times we'll see
someone do a trend and they'll make a
statement without really understanding
if that's the problem so for instance
right in this account there CPAs are
going up a lot right and and they said
well our CPAs are going up but really
the reason is we were an early adopter
into this industry and so our cost per
click was super cheap when we started we
now have more competitors they have
pushed up the the cost per click so
that's the reason our CPA has gone up
right in that was actually that was the
argument in this particular case and the
problem is we're just looking at CPA and
CPC where one of the big numbers who
want to add to that would be some of
that conversion rate and it turns out in
their case competitors were not pushing
up cpc's yet they still were very few in
the industry the conversion rate was
tanking and that's where I want to make
sure we're not looking at just one or
two pieces of data that we're looking at
more of these metrics because they all
have influences on each other so if we
see right big changes to conversion
rates or return on adspend one of the
first things to look at is did your
competitors change their offer right you
might have had a really good offer your
competitor came with a better offer and
suddenly right they're getting the those
conversions and so number one right our
changes to your offers or changes to
competitor offers when you see a big
change number two did something break
I mean landing pages break its just
websites are living entities things come
things go things go out of stock
products no longer sold new products
introduced so did something break right
good question
and then lastly right did tracking
change was an attribution model applied
if you apply an attribution model and
you change how data flows across the
account then your trend analysis right
can only really include data for one the
attribution change your your your trend
account level should be okay but when
you drill into campaigns and ad groups
it's going to be off because you've
changed how conversion data sets now
this is where we look a lot so if we
often want a segment data right average
is hide a lot and it's only only segment
a couple of times so we really get to
the root causes so for instance in this
case right there CPA had gone down a
little bit and it gone down a little bit
so no one was really paying that much
attention right to what was going on
because that's a good change whoa what
would had happened is they launched a
new website that was almost impossible
to navigate on tablet devices and their
tablet CPA was skyrocketing but because
there was so much less traffic from
tablets and desktops no one saw this
issue with tablets because they were
looking at the aggregated data and
because desktop CPA was dropping so much
no one noticed that problem so when
you're trying to look at huge amounts of
data at once right humans are not good
at staring at a massive Excel
spreadsheet in in picking out the five
numbers that matter right that's where
we often want to add visual cues for
ourselves right so heat maps you can
make heat maps in Excel third-party
programs whatnot we can glance at data
in this case just impressions but it
could be conversion rate row loss
whatever and we can quickly see here's
when we get our most impressions right
there's no hunting and looking at a huge
sheet to try to figure out what numbers
are bigger or smaller
and any out wire will just pop out
immediately right we'd see some green
number in the middle of a sea of red
note ah it's not wire we want to look at
that so then when we see right okay now
we know there's something big that's a
problem right usually our first step
then is to isolate it right isolate it
and say let's drill down into the
campaign's of the biggest changes then
maybe even drill down to the ad groups
for the biggest changes and then look at
right our overall data analysis at the
ad group level then we're going to find
right here's what the problem is and
once we see that problem we often might
want to even go look right or may not
see the problem it may even see like
here's the timeframe it happened I'm
going to change history
alright Google logs most not all changes
most changes you make in your accounts
whether it's API editor the interface
correctly and so you can isolate here's
the time frame here's the changes I mean
in this account and this isn't massive
changes but this account had 30,000
changes in you know roughly four weeks
so there's no way you're going to
diagnose write 30,000 lines of data to
see what change affected things we're
going to say here's where it happened
so we can segment down to the campaign
or a group here's the time frame it
happened in so we can usually segment
down to you know a couple of days now we
can look and say okay what changed right
in that spot so then once we've
diagnosed our problem area right we
found here's our campaign here's our ad
group here's whatever is it's wrong
right then we're going to segment a
couple times we're just going to segment
by device maybe network could be
geography time of day different
audiences to see do one of these things
is responsible for the change right do
we have a big change in our CPAs by
device did suddenly our search partner
Network spiked up in traffic did we go
dark in New York City for whatever
reason and and therefore it's where
largest
in the u.s. our puppet are our
impressions drop a lot and that caused
our our loss of conversions right so
then once we figure out here is that the
diagnosis right they want to create an
action plan going forward to fix the
issue sometimes it's as easy as unpause
and a few key words or adding a few bit
modifiers other times it's more you know
a lot more hey we need to you know lay
out a new add testing plan because our
CTR dropped too much and I took our
convergence with it but we don't have
that offer anymore so the offers longer
you know available so we need to come up
with something new that we can use to
get our CTR conversion rates back up
right that's a much more in-depth plan
but the reason we want to look at
interrelated metrics right in this
account their conversions one at fifty
five percent month-over-month none
normally right if you call up your
client or your boss say yep we got fifty
five percent more sounds like that's a
great number but actually in this case a
55% increase in conversions was was not
a good month um
the impressions had gone up ninety four
percent cost went up seventy three
percent
conversions only one at 55 right we look
at that that holistic picture of the
account I realize that Wow our
impressions went up a lot and our cost
went up a lot but because we had a 20%
decrease in conversion rates
we only got fifty five percent more
conversions so now we need to look at
where did our conversion rates fall
right was it hey did we add a bunch of
new keywords and that's why I'm precious
skyrocketed but those key words none of
them converted right and that's we want
to look at here we want to look at our
conversion rates want to look at a month
over month Delta to say hey where do
they fall and then if we don't see any
anyplace they fell when I look to be
added anything new that just didn't
convert right now usually when your your
client or your boss calls you up and
says hey you you pretty much double my
spend last month what's going on right
that does not sound like a fun
conversation right like we doubled your
spend hmm well in reality in this
particular case it was a great month
right
impressions went up 87% up but CTR was
better so clicks on up a hundred and
eight percent even more than impressions
went up and conversion up a hundred and
thirty six percent for most people this
is a very successful month right and so
that's why when you when someone says
hey why did Y change what is exchange
why does Z change that that's an
impossible question in isolation to
answer I might want to look at is okay
so why did it exchange well let's look
at the picture let's see what influences
that particular metric and then see hey
what are these influences how do they
change so we can firmly a quick answer
and so that's what we kind of love these
sort of charts right because if someone
says hey why did Costco up 95 percent
you can hit like two buttons grants to
this and say will cause one up 95
percent because our clicks went up 108
percent and that went up so much because
our CTR was higher so even though
impressions didn't go up when they went
up a lot 87 we have a higher CTR our CPC
actually went down so we got our 8% more
clicks for that budget increase yes it
was a 95 percent budget increase but
because our convergent was higher and
our cpc's were lower your cost per
conversion went down 18 percent and we
got a 136 percent more conversions so
that is a 30-second story from looking
at data for about 15 seconds right
normally when someone says hey why did
my spend double it's often that puts
people in sort of scramble mode and they
spent hours diagnosing things when
visual charts can tell you so much in a
very small amount of time so you can do
this yourself
this is not that complicated data studio
is a tool Google gives away it's free
it's a fantastic tool if someone else
makes the templates for you it is an
incredibly difficult tool to make stuff
from scratch you have to really
understand how a lot of pieces fit
together so we design a lot of studio
data studio templates because we love it
and we have a few people who have the
time to actually sit and work on it so
this is this is Google Data studio where
you can see very quickly right on a page
how the metrics change on the second
page we've got here's the campaign Delta
so you can see the differences by
campaign by metrics so you don't have to
build this yourself this is take several
hours to build but the trick with data
studio if you've never used it before is
setting up your environment correctly if
you don't then what may happen is you go
to add another report and you don't know
which account it's actually working from
or things get really messy very quickly
it's not that hard to set up correctly
if you know what you're looking for
right so on the UM on a third page of
this data studio report are links to
videos that show you how to use it so if
you've never used at a studio write that
the fifth one is getting started with
data studio click on that watch the
video it's not that long but it will
ensure as you use this template other
templates there's a lot of good free
ones out there right that that you're
setting it up correctly and then you
know how to duplicate it and share it
because that way you could even share it
with a client you send it to them and
they can just look at their data
themselves and so you a lot of our
recent webinars have been you know you
should not be doing reporting manually
we're reporting is the largest time sync
of any tasks for a to CNN has people it
is unquestionably the biggest time sync
so places like
a studio which you create templates and
then the data is automatically refreshed
so you you create your report you change
the time frame rate all the data gets
refreshed you hit a download button that
you email it and your reports are
finished right reporting to be real
quick but you need to set the templates
up first it's a good place to start with
those all right and with that I will
turn it back to Dan to see if we have
any questions and thoughts most people
have their questions answered already
and I just want to say if there's
anything that you can add to maybe some
things up if there's just one or two
things that even the most basic person
could do at an introductory level to
improve their failed campaigns what
would those be it would be to look at
where something changed right number one
so if you go just into your Google Ads
account right and you go to the home
screen of your Google Ads account where
the campaigns are there's a chart at the
top of the page right in the chart you
can do something like say show me
conversions and cost per conversion or
show me converse as a clicks Google
chart it up for you then you can
immediately see do you have a change do
you have a trend what is it and that's
an any screen within in Google right you
can go and look at your audience data
and say here's my audience that let me
look at my conversion rates and CPA by
audience and it's a great place just to
get for anybody of any level to see any
sort of quick trend data using the built
in charts that are actually right inside
your Google Ads account great here we
have a couple of questions that have
come in Google is always after us to
change the data attribution model in our
monthly calls I mean usually opposed to
this because it makes it very difficult
to compare year over year with the
conversions and conversion rate so what
are your thoughts on this this is that
so as an overall
idea I love attribution right and simply
learn we have archive presentations
looking at through attribution and
actually go into your question a lot
more depth I'm going to right now if you
look at say your data and you see the
vast majority of your conversions are
one click convert attribution doesn't
matter because you already last click
anyway if you see that most people
taking three or four or five clicks to
convert the the question to ask yourself
is do you want to set bids based upon
how a targeting method affects your end
results if yes then you want to really
put an attribution method in place but
yes it will destroy your year over your
trending where you can still trend in
you know Google Analytics because you
could leave your Google Analytics data
as it is trend in GA but then bid from
your Google Ads account but after
applying at Ridgemont it is a big
decision right although it takes three
seconds to do because it does mess up
your trending but it lets you value
clicks higher than the funnel right to
to the actual value is contributing to
your business so that's the question
what would you rather have right bidding
that affects the entire customer journey
or great trending data you can't have
both you have to take one hopefully that
answered your question
break it looks like you nailed it
spot-on I just want to say thanks again
to you Brad for joining us if you have
any other further questions it didn't
get addressed during today's
presentation just tweet us at simple
alert and we'll get back to you and of
course remember to follow brad geddes on
twitter @ @b G Theory for more
information on PPC best practices and
more so thanks again everyone for
joining us and brad thank you so much as
well thank you Dan for hosting
everything once again
[Music]